I've got so much more personality than  any other guy in here like it's a race  for number two because the like funniest  the most creative guy just walked into  the room  hi Stephanie I'm Skippy this is our  party sort of his but mine Skippy likes  to make t-shirts  yeah yeah yeah yeah because I am in fact  fun and single and ready to meet you I  have other shirts y'all invited two  hottest chicks to this event you should  have invited some uglier broads that he  might have more success like these these  girls okay guys in the room smash or  passy I know the lightning stock right  but Sebastian pass from what you can see  yeah yes we're all through easy right  two and that's generous